you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with kate andrews and anna subri so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages for you now
the telegraph writes about how afghan
special forces personnel could become a
new regiment and fight for britain
similar to the gurkhas
as the u.s withdrawal deadline looms the
taliban says they will allow more
departures that's according to the
guardian
the financial times has the headline u.s
says drone strike foiled fresh attack on
airlift as deadline nears
the times quotes the prime minister
saying britain's terror threat is the
worst in years
the mirror reports on growing fears of
surge in covid infections as pupils
return to school
the daily mail says latest figures show
less than half of patients see their gp
face to face in parts of the country
and we're joined tonight by kate andrews
and anna subray good evening to you both
uh let's start first of all with the
telegraph and their front page the
headline there afghan commandos could
fight for britain like gurkhas uh the
suggestion they could become a new
regiment of the army anna
yeah sounds like a very good idea the
telegraph is reporting from a number of
mps who served with distinction in
afghanistan
tom tugan hart is there uh tobias elwood
uh johnny mercer all of whom have had
experience of these special forces
trained by the british army
and it seems that it's been given a good
wide welcome and it's difficult to see
why it wouldn't be a good idea because
goodness means we have let down the
afghan people we know that there are
still many thousands
out in afghanistan who shouldn't be
there
and goodness knows how we're going to
get them out
so this is the least that we can do
um to continue to some in some way
to support the work that's already been
done in the last 20 years in afghanistan
in case it does seem very much to be a
new idea not something that perhaps was
in the pipeline previously
well i think what's coming out from the
front of the telegraph is that there
were quite a few details that perhaps
journalists had that they weren't able
to report or weren't comfortable
reporting yet until uh the the
operation of of evacuating uh soldiers
and civilians was over and the front
pages detailing to what extent these
afghan soldiers working with the british
troops were putting themselves in the
line of danger going in finding the
interpreters finding those who have the
paperwork going into taliban controlled
areas and getting them out and getting
them over to british paratroopers so i
mean you know it's it's such a story of
of heroism and success on the front page
of the telegraph perhaps details we
wouldn't have wanted to report yet in
case it put any individuals
in jeopardy so it's difficult to say how
long this idea would be in the pipeline
and but the idea that we would be
reaching out to those afghan soldiers
now who are in the uk saying if you want
to be integrated if you want your own
regiment you know all options are open
to you as anna says it's just absolutely
right they've done us so much service
already and it's very important that we
meet them where they're at and hopefully
can uh
recruit them into the army here too
yes and a quote there that they've
proved their loyalty a thousand times
and from the the article anna is it a a
dead cert that this will actually come
to fruition
i genuinely wouldn't know but it it does
seem to have a lot of credibility to it
and it seems very likely and if you've
got good support coming from
important backbenchers um the three i've
just described two former ministers two
chair of select committees and you can
see and i think somebody else and do
forgive me um there's somebody from the
army who is also quoted one of the
senior officers in the army um so i i
think this is something that is
obviously going to get serious
consideration i mean i think
i think the the fact that it looks like
these these remarkable men have done
great brave deeds escape the saying he's
not denied i think the
the thing that is really coming across
and is very striking and very concerning
is that there seemed to be a remarkable
lack of a plan and this was all being
done very last minute we would know for
18 months that the americans were going
to withdraw
and whilst nobody denies that the
taliban has taken over considerably
quicker than anybody predicted including
themselves nevertheless uh it is
striking that there seems to have been
and it's very it is wrong and it's the
fault of this government there hasn't
been a proper plan to evacuate everybody
that should have been evacuated and also
make plans for the future of so many of
these people we still have no details
for example of what afghan refugees
coming to our country where they're
going to live what
the actual arrangements uh for people to
even begin to try to apply to be refuge
refugees to come over to the uk and
there's no plan on any of this it really
is shocking uh meanwhile kate the ft uh
looking at the continued terror threat
and the fact that it is still a very
volatile situation with with fresh
attacks being foiled
yes and it's confirming that the u.s
launched a drone strike um to try to
offset another terror attack on the
kabul airport i saw abc just moments ago
was reporting that
six people died several of them children
um from having to thwart that attack but
there was a car that reportedly was
holding uh lots of bombs it was thought
to be another uh suicide bombing attempt
uh which was stopped by the us but you
know this is raising a lot of questions
the u.s is still there they're still
pushing forward their evacuation efforts
there's still concerns that there could
be yet another attack they're dealing
with isis k the the regional uh group
for isis there which is extremely
violent and pressing forward still with
its attempts to squander the evacuation
and you have jake sullivan the u.s
national security adviser who has said
and i believe quote the president does
not intend to start a new war in
afghanistan but there is now there are
now plans and the president has pledged
that he's going to go after those uh who
set off that first bomb and that there
is probably going to be an increased use
of drones so the idea that the us is out
of afghanistan completely and for good
simply isn't the case it's going to be
more of a matter of boots on the ground
and i i don't think we're necessarily
looking at the end of the u.s presence
in afghanistan but a different kind of
warfare which obviously raises a lot
more questions is this the the end of
the beginning of the of the evacuation
and the retreat and and as anna
mentioned before um unfortunately for
the brits and for almost certainly for
the americans as well they're going to
be many people left behind you should
have gotten out what happens to those
people indeed uh the guardian looking at
um the fact that the taliban saying that
they'll allow more departures
from the airport um it's a forced
corporation isn't it that the u.s are
going to have to have with the taliban
in terms of the the continued evacuation
anna
yes i mean if it enables them to get
some of the people out that they have to
get out there will still be people
there that haven't
been um taken out of afghanistan
including the people who supported the
british
armed forces ngos and so on and so forth
and of course we know that there are
huge pressures on the border i'm sorry
i'd i wouldn't trust the taliban further
than i could throw them
so uh the idea i find it quite
incredible that the americans are going
to somehow stay and
have a presence in afghanistan by
working with the taliban as quite
extraordinary i mean you have to hear
the reports already that are coming out
of
the atrocities that they have committed
and the very
real experiences of people who can't go
back to university that banks haven't
opened and so on and so forth the real
fear that's especially women and
children have
female children have that
this is the end of their lives as they
have known them and they just want to
get out but but what options do the us
have if they don't cooperate in in order
to to make visa evacuations to to see
them through
well this is the difficulty when joe
biden set his deadline and decided not
to waver from it regardless of what was
going on
on the ground he put himself in a
difficult situation where diplomacy
essentially becomes the only answer
because he has decided to evacuate he
has a deadline and and there's no
movement there
now both the us and the uk have hinted
at this idea that diplomacy and
international recognition of the taliban
will be conditional on their respect for
human rights but you know that is a very
broad statement what are the red lines
and are we willing to keep to them as
anna pointed out already we are seeing
the taliban go after comedians we're
seeing them uh killing uh folk singers
and they um there's been some you know
terrifying reports of the treatment of
women already they're already banning
them from certain roles they're taking
all female voices off the airwaves and
that is not respecting human rights as
any of us in this conversation would
know it so what are the uk and the us
going to decide their red lines are and
and when does diplomacy break down i
mean these are these are difficult
questions that we have to ask with many
countries around the world but this is a
particularly important one because of
obviously the us and the uk's legacy in
afghanistan now and and the fact that uh
there was a lot of trust built up
between the afghan people and the us and
the uk for the past 20 years and it does
seem like that trust has been thrown
under a bus
in recent weeks uh given the fact that
the cons conditions started to
deteriorate so quickly and yet um a
certain evacuation and then the
operations behind that evacuation and it
doesn't seem like the u.s in particular
made many changes to make the situation
better
and just a short amount of time to have
a look at the mirror before we go to the
break and the fact that schools when
they go back it's going to be a huge
test as to you know what happens in
terms of numbers of infections and
spreading of coronavirus
yeah we've seen a spike again in
scotland and of course the schools in
scotland went back two weeks ago
and so the schools
that the the mirror is talking about
here of course the schools in england
and wales they're going back in the next
couple of weeks and and it's absolutely
right this is going to be a big test i
do think it's important to say though
that the real test is not the rate of
how many people are getting covered it's
it's actually how many people are going
into hospital and also long coded which
is a very real prop problem but it's the
pressure on the nhs
that is that the test if you like um but
the mirror's right to say that there is
going to be a spike
in infections
uh gps um who see only half of their
patients in person in certain parts of
the country i mean i know quite a few
people who actually prefer
uh the fact that they can
instantly have access to their gp and
say it's quite efficient um but there's
this article sort of suggesting it's not
not a good thing kate
um well look the difficulty is nobody
can really say what the exact percentage
should be in person or or over the phone
or on zoom it should be patient-led um
and you know we can't sit here and know
exactly what that breakdown's going to
be the problem is that it's increasingly
being reported that patients aren't very
happy and whilst there are lots of
things that are way more efficient to do
over zoom perhaps getting a repeat
prescription uh perhaps an issue you've
already seen your gp about you just want
to follow up with but for so many people
for their physical and mental health
which we'll come on to in the next story
it's really important to be having these
appointments in person so the fact that
in a quarter of districts it's less than
half of patients who are being granted
face-to-face appointments is going to be
very grating to a lot of people who
let's not forget last spring stayed at
home when the nhs didn't have great
messaging about still showing up to make
sure you see your gp um for even routine
appointments to make sure we do that
preventative health care when at that
time we really convinced people to stay
away from hospital stay away from gps we
have a lot of catching up to do and the
last thing i'd flag is that whilst a lot
of people like that immediate access for
their gp even online they're not getting
it the story says that some people are
waiting three weeks for just a gp
appointment alone that doesn't feel like
comprehensive healthcare
and anna there are certain things as
kate suggests that that you do actually
need to physically see your gp for
aren't there
yes there are um i look i make no
complaints about my gp surgery uh i had
calls to uh call them during the
pandemic obviously
i'm not going to bore you with the
details as to why
but the service i received which was via
the nurse and then antibiotics you know
straight down to the pharmacy and so on
and so forth excellent the problem is as
kate's identified and the report of the
male identifies is that there's an awful
lot of people in all sorts of different
parts of the country who should be being
able to go and see their gp who aren't
getting to see their gp and it doesn't
make sense because our hospitals are
open they are functioning all the
clinics are open you can go and see a
consultant and you can go and into a e
or the other departments and of course
they've got this huge backlog which
they're trying to deal with but i think
that the the short thing is is that
actually we have a crisis that is
developing very quickly in our gp
practices
and in the meantime they've got to open
up because if you like the pr
is not good and there are a lot of
people who believe you can't get to see
your gp in any event
and kate the guardian uh suggesting that
an estimated eight million people in
england with mental health problems
can't get specialist help
so getting access to mental health care
was a really big problem on the nhs
before covet hit and it was very
difficult in many areas to be able to to
see a therapist or a psychiatrist um if
you needed that kind of care for your
anxiety depression and other mental
health illnesses cobit has made the
problem a lot worse it's also grown the
number of people very understandably who
want to get access to these services and
being locked up being in lock down for
months on end is not a normal human
condition and a lot of people have
suffered the mental consequences of that
is yet another example of this huge
backlog we have now in the nhs it's
estimated to be over 5 million on nhs
england now but the health secretary
estimates it could go up to 13 million
people those sound like big numbers but
i don't think we have acutely felt what
that will actually mean if people aren't
getting access to these kinds of key
treatments you know yet another reminder
that mental health should be taken as
seriously as physical health but that we
were woeful on this before the pandemic
hit and now i think we're really going
to start to feel the consequences of
that